leslie what's up so my question
um for you is how
my husband and i have really struggled
um in
our marriage um most recently just
within the last two and a half years
after our son was born um and
my husband is constantly saying like you
know i just need you to respect me more
i need you to respect me more
and what does that mean
does that mean do whatever i want and
what i say
um no i think he
in his eyes he wants me to
maybe put him first um and i have
no problem doing that um but
a lot of times in my eyes he
does not do anything to
deserve it or
put me first or our marriage or
our son first um how long have you been
married
we've been married um it'll be four
years um
this coming 2021. so is this
is this new for him is it like it's
emerged over the last couple years did
things change when you had a kid
uh or has he always been pretty much
women need to know their role and this
is how my house is gonna run
no no he's not like that um
he's not like that um he is just
um
it's it honestly it's mostly when our
when our son was about five or
four or five months old um he
might my husband is kind of just um
and dave has on had talked about the
enneagram
on the show so i got the book my husband
is
an eight like his face showed up when i
read chapter eight
like that is my son or that is my
husband
and um he is in
um law enforcement and i think that a
lot of his um
personality comes from the anxiety and
the stress of his job
which i clearly understand um but
i too am a full-time working health care
professional and i work more than
time um and i
come home and i do all the things
the only thing my husband contributes to
our marriage
and parenthood is his paycheck and
it's heartbreaking yeah um
he's he's just not a warm and fuzzy
place to come home to
um have you told him this yes
and how did that conversation go like
when you sat down not in a fight
and but in a what i would call an
intimate moment
and said hey look i know your job is
really hard
and for the past couple of years it has
been super hard
both existentially practically
it's been really tough you're there in
st louis y'all have gotten it worse on
top of worse on top of worse right
yeah brutal
all sides telling your husband both
explicitly and implicitly you're kind of
worthless
and he has a kid which throws a
wrench in the gears of every marriage
good ones
heart broken marriages all of them
having a kid is hard
and then he's got a wife who's working
full full full time on top of
another job right and you're picking up
your share of trauma
during all the medical stuff man you've
been living a zoo too
so i'm hearing that that's a lot of
conflict a lot of storms a lot of
stuff and you sit down and you walk this
through with him and then say
i need you to be a warm person to come
home to i need to be able to
fall into you i need you to be there to
catch me
because i love you and i'm going to be
there to catch you and his response is
what
well i'm just not a touchy feely person
or you know and that's that's kind of
what he says like you know i want to
you know when he comes home i want to
give him a hug and and show him
you know i'm glad you're home and he
every time i go to hug him comes up with
an excuse to not hug me
or if i want to go to kiss him he'll
kind of roll his eyes that he has to
um kiss me or so is there other is there
other things going on
no no um you know not that i'm aware of
i mean
he's he's do you have a strong intimate
life
no no um
he thinks that i'm he says that he's
distant from me because i'm
critical okay um is there some truth is
there some truth to that
um i think there is but it's
i think that there is but it's because
i'm constantly telling him like i need
you to show up and help me with our son
i need you to show up and help me with
this and
like and so here's here's what happens
here's what happens
you get into a dance where suddenly you
sound very similar to the sergeant he
works for
or you sound very similar to his mom
and he suddenly becomes very similar to
every stereotypical police officer
he becomes he becomes very similar to
probably men that you've had in your
life in the past whether that's your dad
or your brother's this distant cycle
and your role in that is to slowly begin
to
point out what he needs to be doing
which turns into
what something like a job performance
review which turns very quickly into
complaining
frustration not that it's not warranted
but it just turns into this cycle
and he turns into because right now i
guarantee you he's thinking in his head
my home isn't a warm place for me to
come home to
and now y'all now you're locked into a
figure eight that you can't get out of
right right and because he's right too
he comes home and he gets a list of job
chores
and he just wants to sit for a minute
and you're thinking rightfully
you can't sit i've been working all day
i'm exhausted
i need help with dinner hey look you
have a child over here why don't you go
love that
right and it just gets into this
loop-de-loop-de-loop-de-loop
and it's heartbroken heartbroken
heartbreaking and one of you
if not both of you have to turn
and bravely face that dance
otherwise it just grinds you down and
that's when you're gonna
take that flirty text with somebody else
one step too far that's where he's gonna
end up just staying out later and lit
right and that's when you end up
with this wedge between your marriage or
you end up
40-year roommates that's just the way he
is that's just the way i am and you live
a silent
burning simmering life and he lives a
distant hit the recliner pro my feet up
life
and both of you are worth more than that
but both of you are going to have to
lean
way into the discomfort and since i'm
only talking to you
the only person you can handle on this
end is you
right and at some point you're going to
have to say
i love you more than life itself and i
also love our baby
and i don't want to be somebody who's
acts like your mom
i don't want to be someone who nags you
i want to create a world
that's a warm safe um
like haven from the world that ugly
place that your husband wades into every
day on behalf of his community on behalf
of his state and his country
i want to create a safe warm place for
you when you get home
and for me to do that here's what i need
and approach it from
here's how i want to lean into you but
i've got to have you leaning back
as and that's a different approach then
if you would just do these things then
this would does that make sense
one is a tethering in and one is a job
performance
one is a like a ceo review right
and here's the thing i've worked with
police officers for a long time
no one no one no one will ever know what
they go through
and i've also worked with healthcare
professionals for a long
long time no one will ever know what
they go through
and i can't recommend strongly enough
that you two
the conversations start with you because
you're the only person you can control
i wish he would do it but he won't
i wish uh you're gonna have to lean into
that at the beginning
and say here's what i need and you're
you all two are at a point now where
y'all need to go see somebody
right and i have i have been seeing
someone and he won't or
or he's open to it sort of ish okay no
okay nope that's that's weak ah okay
i've loved loved love those those police
officers my whole life
and it's heartbreaking it's hard but
i've
i've known those guys and they've got
great hearts and
there's there comes a moment when if
they open that door
there's a fear that i can never close it
again and i understand that
from the stuff they've seen the stuff
they've experienced their childhood
stuff all of it
so at the end of the day you can work on
you
and you can continue to model and lean
in what i'm going to tell you is
nagging complaining fighting solves
nothing ever it becomes a burden that
you carry
and if he will call me i'll tell him the
reverse of that
demanding respect without earning it
demanding
um warmth without giving it
again as a fool's errand it never works
right
and at the end of the day both of you in
your own weird
loving ways are choosing the misery that
y'all are both living in
and i hate that for you
okay until he decides
that he wants to deeply connect with you
at the end of the day all you can work
on is you i wish i had a more
optimistic thing to tell you i can tell
you this though i can tell you this
leslie
i've sat with a lot of police officers a
lot of
them who have made some extraordinary
moves in their life
one of the chief mentors in my life in
the crisis world dr andy young
works almost exclusively with police
officers behind closed doors
and helping heal marriages and helping
heal hearts and helping
those guys deal with the extraordinary
stress that they're under
all the time every day and so i'm going
to tell you
that growth and and wellness is super
possible
it takes some work but it's super
possible and it's the furthest thing
from weak
weakness is running weakness is hiding
facing those old demons those old
dragons that's the hard stuff right
that's that's bravery
and so have your husband call me i'd
love to talk to him he won't call me but
i'd love to talk to him and
if not i want you to not give up on him
keep loving him keep doing the things
that you know
make you well don't give in to the
temptations of
somebody else outside your marriage
that's not going to heal you don't give
in to the temptations
of just completely disconnecting that's
not going to heal you
but continue to be honest with him
continue to show up continue to tell him
i love you and i want to make this a
warm safe place for you to come home to
and it's going to be exhausting and it's
going to take energy you probably don't
have
because you're a kick and butt nurse
you're a contingent or kicking butt i
just said that
you may be a surgeon you're a kicking
butt health professional and you're a
full-time mom too
and that's a lot
it's a lot my hope and prayer for you is
that this is a season this is a hard
season
um and that you and your husband are
going to find each other
but all you can do is take care of you
so keep seeing a a counselor
keep leaning into it and keep leaning
into the relationship
and that's all you can do
i'm sorry leslie those those
conversations break my heart because
here's the thing good folks
men listening to this women listening to
this single people couples
it's a decision at the end of the day
it's a decision when your wife leans in
to kiss you that you turn your face
because
she's not feeling the blame it's a
decision
when your husband gets home from a crazy
day of work even if you're tired
to not go over there and hug him that's
a choice
it's a choice to just stay at home while
she's out working two jobs and you
thinking
well i just got to find the right
opportunity for no dude go do something
that's a choice
it's a choice to not say hey we haven't
slept together
in a month and things are really weird
and i'm uncomfortable and i don't know
what to do next but i don't like this
one of you has to say it first
it sucks but at the end of the day it's
a choice
both people are choosing to live like
this guys and you don't have to do it
you're worth being in a relationship
you're worth being well
you're worth being loved man everybody
is worth being loved